STEALS.
OH, DON'T DO THAT.
>> MY GOO
KENNARD IN DOUBLE FIGURES.
RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S NICE. A REAL
WEAPON
ISH WAINWRIGHT KNOCKED DOWN A
COUPLE
SHOOT-AROUND, LETHAHA
OH, C
HE BEGAN HIS COLLEGE CAREER AT
VIRGINIA TECH A A
WEAK SIDE IS DEV TO
UNDERSTAND.  MAN STEVEN ADAMS.
>> Kevin: BALL ACROSS THE LANE,
GETS TO HISCP WEAVING THROUGH T.
RISING UP ON TWO DEFENDERS AND
STICKS I EURO WAS A NO FROM
MURRAY.
UPON, CHRIS PAUL ON THE
HIGH SCREEN AND  GETTING TEN
OVERALL PICK WITH THE NICE MOVE
INSIDE.
MORRIS HAS TWO. 10s LAST YEAR.
CHIOZZA, OUT TO LOONEY.
ONCE PAUL GETERE.
>> ON THE IT FROM AN AREA WHERE
THEY SAY DON'T LOVE HOW IF HE CT
WITH ONE HAND,
IS 43.
HE SCORED I AT WISCONSIN,NOW YOE
HE WASN'T GOING TO.
OVERPLAYED EVERYTHING THEY TRIED
TO DO.
>> PAUL OLYMPIC
PERFORMANCE.
CAUGHT COVID, HAD TO RAMP UPS S.
LOOKING TO DOUBLE, BUT PUT HIM
FREE-THROW LINE.
GAME.
UNABLE TO POKE IT WAY FROM THE
SUNS HAVE THE BALL.NEEDLE.
>> Reggie: CHRIS PAUL, THE POIN
GOD POINTS PER GAME.
HE WAS THE
>> Kevin: PAULRLY, JUST
REALLY SAYING GREATN THE LAST C
GAMES.
>> Eddie: PUN
INTENDED BEING A ROD BOT.
JUST PLAYING THE CONSECUTIVE ST
LARRY NANCE.
ALDRIDGE.
PAUL SCREENS IN.
GETS THE BUCKET, AN
BUT ALWAYS A THREAT. THE LEAGUEE
LAST TWO YEARS IN CLUTCH TIME,
THTH SHOOTING.
MIKAL GETS THE GOOD OPEN L, OVE.
LEFT.
IN HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTOCOLS,